bros before this video begins extremely
important announcement
the biggest sale of the year
is happening right now with g-fuel bogo
buy one get one that's right you heard
it right
you buy a jeep fuel and you get the
g-field free
so basically if you buy g-fuel you get
infinite g-fuel the math checks out
no codes are necessary but if you want
to be a real one enter
code pewdiepie or use the link in
description it's a great chance to suck
up smg fuel
it's the greatest drink of all time i
drink it every day it tastes amazing
everyone that tries it says it tastes
amazing it's healthier than normal
energy drinks
i just want you guys to take advantage
of this huge sale
there's also exclusively a classified
flavor
that's right what is it pick up the
pewdiepie one try some different flavors
up the classified one
huh what is that this sale goes on from
the 26th
to the first of june so make use of it
don't say i didn't warn you
okay on with the video how's it going
my name is and welcome to
friday
[Music]
is it on an actual friday i think it
might be on a friday
we did it this means we're immortal
i don't know how that works okay he's
back
austin bradley the man the legend
what
oh here's where oh come on burrito
glasses get out of here
okay that's kind of sick not gonna lie
no don't do it whoa
oh it flexes no way that's so i didn't
even notice that
hold up that's so cool
whoa
this guy ginormous peepee
yo get pizza react to this because this
is truly amazing
all right this is a top button do you
remember the fat red haired guy
i think i have seen this yeah damn
well done i feel like uh this is really
inspirational because i
uh probably a lot of people that get to
this state i mean i don't want to sound
rude but they
i can imagine they feel like a hopeless
cause right
there's no way you know things can
change from here but he did
it's possible amazing congrats man how i
met the man himself
sort of okay okay
scuffed okay
well there you have it good nice i will
never forg
remember i never never forget what the
[ __ ] am i saying
largest known human poo is 20 centimeter
come on
and dates back to a 9th century viking
viking poo legendary viking po
oh hell yeah 27
surely that's not the largest
to all the americans 20 centimeters are
zero points here they're miles
stupid american
the british queen with boring hands the
swedish king with his hundreds of
funny hats he just can't stop having
funny hats
he is such a funny hat man amazing
youtuber streamer transformation we got
michael reeves went from
middle schooler and high school
budget keanu reeves homeless jesus gamer
hasn't seen sunlight in four days to one
of the low res
npcs from gta san andreas that's spot on
well done
i can't even be mad at that oh sh
oh i've hacked felix computer
and found this who posted this
you sneaky who did this
i have no idea who did it i genuinely
don't know
but uh not man i can't show it here
though but yeah
it's a behind-the-scenes footage for a
coco i wasn't allowed to post it
what's the most annoying thing your
girlfriend does nothing to me she's
perfect
insert all here well just kidding she's
violent i'm scared she will hurt me if
she sees his mercy
nothing has changed oh my god the way he
climbs up that door is like
[Laughter]
some things never change domestic abuse
am i rag gamers i'm joking
everyone's always talking about phil's
legs but when was the last time you saw
his ears
oh i don't have ears i don't
wow you caught me have you ever had sex
with a duck i'm not supposed to tell you
in one day's
but no very unfortunate
hey sick fan art love it
then at it then you're such a dumb
animal stupid monkey
one person of your species took a [ __ ]
in the shower oh [ __ ] you're right
guys see this has to stop becoming a
meme i will not be known as the [ __ ] in
the shower
guy all right what if what if i that's
my legacy i'll become some proverb about
not shooting in the shower
don't cheat in shower cause shower stick
on you
holy sh i'm inside of minecraft how old
is minecraft no
funniest tick-tock of all time the title
pdp yeah sometimes i get tired of going
the thing is my camera quality is so low
that i have to take a new screenshot
because i can't get a screen cap from
the video it's a real problem
low quality videos
was watching an old emergency video no
oh go yeah
i keep telling you guys if i ever
disappear
or if anything happen damn he looks so
real
he looks so full of life it looked like
cheeseburger
just ate it very nice
it's kind of hypnotizing i can't stop
looking at it
stop it small peepee all right i posted
his
photo for new merch jack says guns you
and felix should try
doing a lifting competition against each
other loser has to misuse
machines and planet fitness
well that shouldn't be difficult no one
will care
if we do that what's the problem
i wish they had planet fitness here i'm
so curious about it
no i can't wear the same dress as
yesterday that's weird and gross
boys hey i'm wearing gray today hey look
at
that
yeah i got two t-shirts in my closet
i sent all my clothes to japan right
and i didn't feel like i should buy more
clothes because that's just a waste and
more stuff to send over
because i was ready to move and then
obviously everything happened in the
world epic
but then i got really comfortable just
wearing the same clothes i'm like this
is kind of awesome i don't have to think
about what i wear
it makes laundry a lot easier too i mean
come on if you're looking for
some really hype high quality black
t-shirts which is minimal i recommend
the tsuki one but in black
very stylish very clean high quality
this will last you a long time pick up
seven of these bad boys
and you're good to go it took you five
years to finish this
wowie i like it though i don't [ __ ]
believe you liar
tricky ass spat art i love it oh my god
again
feels before and after minecraft
addiction uh-huh actual sense of style
after bruh
i know minimalism is kind of cringe but
it's good for the environment
and it's the idea of be satisfied with
what you have
okay filling life with product isn't
going to make you more fulfilled
you're just feeling temporary
satisfactions
that when they fade you feel empty and
need to fulfill again
and again and again is a problem
solve it free yourself brothers we're
not even trying anymore are we
it's been seven years drawing pewds legs
what do y'all think i love it you worked
hard and you deserve the
recognition late yogurt closet
[Music]
oh i need to do this
oh i need to do this oh bless a dog
he doesn't know oh that's okay
oh that's great ah
poor poochie edgar would run to me maya
would run too
much yeah i think that's pretty simple
being a jubilee fan being a pewdiepie
fan they collab you get onto the collab
you
win tyler he's the one that sets me out
right away
well done tyler i'll never say yo again
average
you jubilee fan average jubilee enjoy
i don't understand it's the same
this is [ __ ] goals right here i need
to start pumping more
god damn god damn are you still
so weak so much strong
oh someone tried my workout routine
thank you oh wow you lost
40 of your body weight oh wow what
impressive results
incredible they said it couldn't be done
oh my god
me and marta were watching this and
we're like who does he look like
he i swear i've seen him before oh my
god finally
dude omniman the best the greatest the
goldest
dear felix nasa finally managed to
acquire the resources
to build your tower nice now you just
have to put them together
okay next tape tambourine meme is long
dead
do you have an idea of how long it takes
to manufacture 7.6 billion tambourines
uh yeah i'm sure you're gonna tell me no
okay
it's time some dreams never die we will
build a tower one day
she graduated and celebrate with gpu
based
very nice everyone says this with the
pie flavor best flavor
everyone knows this glorious taste
taste bud go um what is that
average pewdiepie submission enjoyer
there they are
no well how do you think it's so cheap i
mean come on what do you expect with
ikea
the sad reality and i think they pay
their taxes in germany or something
pewdiepie i can't believe people still
doing giveaways holy [ __ ] so annoying
pewdiepie
massive giveaway okay i get the joke
but then people got all toxic and we're
like okay
i'll say this once and for all giveaways
on youtube is what i have a problem with
because you're buying subs
likes uh comments and it's a way to
boost your video in the algorithm the
youtube algorithm is like oh this gets a
lot of traction
i'm not sure how effective it still is
but it used to be a
a sure way to get your video to trending
and stuff like that
and uh you saw a lot of channels abusing
it
that didn't deserve to get on these uh
trending feeds
so yeah it's annoying in that sense but
it's also annoying in the other sense
that there's
they're doing it on a pretense that it's
something nice for your fans like i want
to give back but in reality
you are the one that's benefiting from
it like don't pretend
i'm giving back to fans five of them
like what five people get something
while you get a lot of money and views
like that's what i have a problem with a
company's doing giveaways whatever like
that's been a thing since i was a child
whatever they
it's not the same as an instagram post
okay
a giveaway he said giveaway back then
now he don't give away
he's so hypocrite toxic idiot hate him
now
he's speaking the language of gods i
can't believe i actually posted this
nine years ago well done thank you thank
you me from now
seven years ago i can't read i'm joe
biden's husband
haha it's probably edited americans
yeah i got so many comments saying this
clip wasn't edited but look
his husband's name is jill but it really
sounds like joe
and i'll prove it i'm joe biden
oh he really sounds like joe come on
but wait wait wait for me to say i'm
jill biden's husband but it sounds like
joe biden
wait for it wait for it wait for it
[Music]
no no he doesn't say joe biden he says
joe biden you can hear
look no he doesn't say jill biden that's
what i say but
no he doesn't say joe biden he see it
sounds
so similar he says joe biden you can he
isn't that crazy
the funniest part of this is actually
that she tries to hug him
like then her hand gets caught in the
mask so she
gets straight the clip that keeps on
coming
[Laughter]
america dumb extremely rare italian
falco oh
he demanded pasta hey
okay new intro question right
[Music]
love it huge ginormous dick
come on come on come on
come on you prefer that little chest
against my giant ass
automatic sorting system huh how much is
a 10 uber ride
how close is miami to florida
[Music]
uh whoa sick setup bro
got the key cap oh
[Music]
that was clean dude my friend says my
setup will make the friday poop but
where he was wrong
all right that's it for friday
i know this is a bit confusing because i
just took two days off but i'm gonna
take another couple days off
and then between seven and five days
what seven plus
five uh thirteen between the seventh and
thirteen i'll be away as well just so
you know
okay hey i get summer holiday
this year very nice and so to save uh
check out the merch 110 million club
baby get this one
very nice or perhaps zero death hoodie
looks very good
look at him glorious all right guys
professor
[Music]
and you can't go to the zoo need to go
to the [ __ ] loop
i got something something for you and
you leave it
[Music]
did it go with it i got something for
[Music]
you
you